[Musique]
les élus du département ont visité la
cuisine autonome du collège bourbon un
collège engagé dans l'utilisation de
produits pays dans la préparation de ces
places ou à près de 70% de ses
condiments et pour aller plus loin dans
cette démarche cet établissement et le
département signé une convention avec la
filière volaille à la reine
ce partenariat démontre que si on veut
travailler ensemble on peut le faire ce
d'autant plus que les produits agricoles
de la région sont des produits de
qualité et are alive pays fait partie
justement de ces produits de qualité et
bien il nous appartient au département
de soutenir ses producteurs pour que par
une fois l'avis de nos marmailles
désormais ils sont 22 établissements du
secondaire engagés dans cette convention
volaille pays visant à proposer plus de
volailles dans les menus une démarche
qui veut améliorer la qualité des repas
servis promouvoir la consommation de
produits pays auprès des élèves et
favoriser le développement de la
production locale
voilà l les produits importés on se bat
tous à bien votre éclair chez nous ses
trois simples dons
après c'est le but cela crée de l'emploi
en fait très peur on a installé s'est
décidée petit sûr pas de 600 hectares et
d'élevage puis on a en charge de la
restauration scolaire dans 77 collège
public le département envisage
d'augmenter de 13 % la part des produits
locaux dans les cantines d'ici 2020
[Musique]